buon pomeriggio per parlarvi del mio
attuale lavoro ho bisogno di portarli
con me indietro nel tempo di circa 25 o
26 anni fa io adesso 38 anni quindi vi
riporto a quando ne avevo 12 13
il contesto è quello di un piccolissimo
paesino dell'entroterra calabrese
collinare e ho bisogno di stringere
ancora più la scala e vi porto in quella
che era la mia cameretta che condividevo
con mio fratello a quell'età io come
praticamente tutti i miei coetanei in
paese
ascoltavo tantissima tantissima musica
in maniera attiva
ho bisogno di specificare di quello che
intendo se io avessi oggi 12 anni
prenderei smartphone attraverso diverse
piattaforme
spotify youtube teaser e quant'altro
potrei scegliere di ascoltare
gratuitamente tutta la musica che voglio
nel momento in cui una canzone non mi
piacesse potrei andare avanti
cambiare tutto il resto mentre quando
ero piccolo io e tanti di voi anche
c'era questo mezzo fantastico che sapevo
ricordate era la cassettina avere una
cassettina al tempo significava trovare
una persona dalla quale copiarla e in
genere erano i fratelli maggiori le
sorelle maggiori del dei miei compagni
oppure aspettare che arrivasse una
fantomatica paghetta diciamo così per
poter avere accesso a una banca e le
acquista quindi quando decide di
ascoltare musica dovevi proprio farlo
dove di volerlo e io ero un grande fan
della musica pesante ascoltavo il rock
ed heavy metal a 12 anni mio fratello
subiva questa cosa su più fronti perché
come ognuno che trova degli idoli a
quell'età
io ho tempestato la stanza di poster la
mia stanza per aveva una particolarità
se io mettevo i piedi sul letto mi
bastava alzare la mano così e toccava il
soffitto soffitto in legno allora non mi
sono limitato riempire a tappezzare le
tab le pareti di poster
l'ho fatto anche sul soffitto e mio
fratello
voto ascoltava la musica sdraiato sul
mio letto con walkman con le batterie e
guardavo i poster attaccati su di quelli
presenti sulle pareti in questo momento
di ricordo veramente 0
marit benissimo tutti i poster attaccati
su mettevo play alle cassettine e
immaginavo non mi interessava e
commentiamo così non mi interessava
sapere cosa provasse un grande artista
che suonava davanti a centomila persone
50 mila persone
a me interessava capire quale fosse
davvero la vita che conducesse a monte
quale fosse l'emergenza che lo portava a
decidere attivamente di fare musica
e mentre sognavo di poter entrare in
quelle menti non avevo alcun codice con
me io non ero un musicista ero piccolino
non ho mai chiesto alcuno strumento i
miei genitori
altrimenti mi avrebbero comprato allora
utilizzavo i suoni prodotti dalla bocca
dalla lingua dai denti per provare a
imitare le percussioni utilizzavo il
corpo suonandolo senza alcun codice in
maniera molto selvaggia per seguire il
batterista ovviamente è una volta
imparate ritornelli come un po tutti
sotto la doccia mentre si cucina
canticchiavo i temi mi innamoravo anche
dei temi di chitarra e limitavo con la
voce i temi di basso e limitava con la
voce
facciamo un piccolo salto in avanti di
circa quattro anni a 17 anni chiese ai
miei genitori la batteria nè accordarono
questa cosa non so se ne sono pentiti
perché la batteria stava al primo piano
sopra il negozio di alimentari che
avevano i miei genitori
io ero un fan delle ri meta adesso una
volta tutti i pomeriggi veramente come
un forsennato il vicinato conosceva il
mio operato mi vedeva crescere come
batterista siamo formati
scusate abbiamo formato le prime band
assieme agli amici fino a un momento in
cui si è aperto un bivio l'università in
quel momento io decisi di iscrivermi
all'università è di continuare a suonare
me la presi molto comoda l'università
devo dire la verità proprio perché
decisi suonare contemporaneamente
iniziano ad arrivare le prime proposte
di collaborazione sono stato batterista
e cantante per diverse band riusciva a
racimolare anche qualche sport mi
mettevo i viaggi nei quali andremo a
vedere le band che mi piacevano andava
bene ri festival tutto sulle mie spalle
università finisce dopo molto tempo
perché ripeto che la sono presa comoda e
arriva il momento di trovarsi un lavoro
che sono architetto lavoravo part time
in alcuni studi di architettura ma è
stato solo grazie alla musica al aver
moltiplicato i gruppi in cui suonavo a
farmi quadrare le spese a fine mese
allora iniziai a dare anche lezioni di
batteria ma avevo un'esigenza che era
quella di provare a capire cosa ci fosse
prima delle lezioni di strumento e
allora mi iscrissi a lord sul werke
italiano che è la una linea pedagogica
per appunto per la propedeutica musicale
con bambini e adulti seguì per tre anni
viaggiando facendo spola con roma è al
primo anno
incontrai la body percussion body corpo
per caso in percussione per intenderci a
questo e body percussion il filo si è
atteso da solo con quando quali periodo
in cui stavo sdraiato sul letto a
suonare in una maniera assolutamente
indisciplinata e le cose che mi
piacevano e quindi ho scoperto che c'era
un modo di suonare senza avere strumenti
che era vicino a quello che serviva a me
per sognare presso ai agli artisti che
mi piacevano durante poi un periodo di
convalescenza di circa 30 35 giorni a
casa decisi di prendere un piccolo
registratore e di registrare dei pattern
ritmici delle frasi ritmiche scusate e
creare il mio primo pezzo
il pezzo si chiama the deep il profondo
un po per narcisismo un po per tentare
questo esperimento cg rai anche un video
e lo mise su youtube
la cosa mi divertiva e funziona allora
iniziai a cercare oltre quello che era
il mio corpo ha iniziato a prendere gli
oggetti presenti in casa
come quelli che avete voi e ho iniziato
a comporre quello che è stato il mio
primo disco si chiama juke box che
ottenne da legambiente il patrocinio
sulla stampa e diciamo l'etichetta di
progetto green perché io utilizzo
soltanto oggetti usati pezzi di scarto
eccetera come questo voi versate
dell'uovo delle creme dentro lo tappate
questo serve per spalmare sul pane ma
potrebbe fare anche molto altro
[Musica]
questa mi sentite ok ciao ciao che
questa era la prima delle conseguenze
inaspettate dei miei trip mentre stavo
sul letto la seconda che per me è molto
più importante il fatto che in calabria
e sicilia
io dopo la nascita di questo progetto
che si chiama io sono ha attivato una
serie di laboratori permanenti con
bambini e adulti e in più mi muovo in
giro per l'italia per fare dei workshop
in sostanza io utilizzo dei frammenti
dall'inglese loop delle ripetizioni
faccio delle porzioni ritmiche melodiche
piccole comprensibili anche da chi non
fa musica
quindi quando nella durante l'ascolto
nella vostra testa ogni cosa nasce è
riuscito a seguirla si posiziona in una
zona che vi permette di accogliere il
loop e il frammento che inserirò dopo
dal punto di vista didattico l'utilizzo
del frammento del loop mette chiunque e
ve lo posso assicurare perché
certificata sul campo nella durante
scusate mette chiunque nella condizione
di poter apprendere perché la richiesta
fatta ad ogni singola persona che sia
alta così o alta così la richiesta è
molto molto semplice quindi se io ho una
cellula ritmica semplice dic 1 2 e 3
anche dopo sei giorni e anche con i
ragazzini che hanno una certa
sensibilità io lavoro anche all'interno
di percorsi terapeutici anche quei
ragazzini alla fine ce la fanno e non
solo la mia richiesta è bassa e si alza
man mano che posso chiedere di più al
ragazzino all'adulto questo pone la
persona che segue i miei laboratori di
fronte alla possibilità di far crescere
la propria autostima perché intanto
utilizziamo come prima cosa il corpo il
corpo ricordiamoci che è il primo e
unico trasmettitore diciamo così per noi
io sto qua in mezzo a voi vedete che sud
perché il mio corpo di comunica
stanchezza per i giorni di tour che
comunica emozioni di comunica il fatto
che io ho tirato fuori questa
improvvisazione quello che potevo in
pochissimo tempo i miei occhi di
comunicano delle cose e il corpo a
comunicare con voi
quando io tolgo il mezzo
che possa essere una batteria una
chitarra un basso e metto letteralmente
nelle mani di piccoli e grandi
la possibilità di fare musica qualcosa
che non avevano manco nemmeno ma
immaginate di farlo in gruppo con altri
10 15 persone io faccio un lavoro
inconsapevole in fondo sulla personalità
di questi esseri alti così così
grandissimo il lavoro è quello di dare
la possibilità di dire la propria
infatti nelle performance che facciamo
con il gruppo di adulti di 25 adulti
residenti diciamo così tra calabria e
sicilia che ho fondato e con quasi
cinquanta ragazzini di cui altri venti
hanno queste sensibilità di cui parlo
seguono dei percorsi di terapia quando
facciamo la performance nessuno sta lì a
vedere quanto siamo figli oppure a
capire quanto riusciamo a sublimare di
ciò che abbiamo fatto quello è
l'ennesimo momento di verifica pone la
body percussion l'utilizzo di strumenti
non convenzionali che arrivano da casa
pone tutti nella condizione di poter
accedere alla musica
non parliamo di professionisti di
musicisti
parliamo di persone che stanno bene
assieme ad altre persone facendo
qualcosa che nemmeno immaginano di fare
a me questo basta e avanza
io so se qualcuno di voi ha mai parlato
nel tubo della scottex o ha mai giocato
con la grattugia se non l'avete fatto
fatelo io ho deciso di farlo per lavoro
e che mi segue si diverte un sacco
grazie
[Applauso]